what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another edition of the tinfoil
chronicles I haven't made one of these
videos in a while but I had an idea
yesterday that I thought was good enough
for a video but I will admit it is some
major tin foil and it's probably not
likely to come true but let's have some
fun anyway I'm not sure if anyone has
ever talked about this before but as far
as I know I haven't heard anyone discuss
this exact possibility yet as I was
thinking about the prince that was
promised prophecy I started to wonder if
this could be a play on words and what I
mean by that is what if the prince who
was promised means it is some kind of a
gift or offering to someone what if this
prince was promised to the knight king
could this be the reason why the knight
king has become so active as of lately
could the knight King becoming south to
get the prince who is promised to him
only John and Daenerys do not know this
yet they aren't aware that anything was
promised to the knight King maybe
Daenerys and John's baby will be the
prince who was promised and the knight
King knows this so he is coming to get
the baby that was promised to him as an
offering the knight King has had several
opportunities to kill Jon Snow but for
some reason he hasn't and have been
wondering why before I discuss this any
further I have to go back track some so
I can explain why I think this is a
possibility
in the television show we learned that
the children of the forest are the ones
who created the original Knight King the
very first Knight king who came during
the long night just like we heard in one
of old man's tales the children of the
forest created the night King because
they were at war and they needed a
powerful weapon to defend themselves and
their sacred weirwood trees
for you you made the White Walkers we
were at Ward we're being slaughtered our
sacred trees cut down we need to defend
ourselves from whom from you from then
but as we all know something happened
that caused our children or the forest
to lose control of their weapon and now
the night king and his army seemed to be
seeking some kind of vengeance now in
the books there is a different night's
king but I think they could be merging
both of these characters together to
form the night king that we know in the
show there must be some kind of reason
why they lay dormant for so many years
and are just now deciding to start
attacking and eventually coming south of
the wall during the first long night
there was a legendary figure called the
last hero and he was the one who set out
with 12 men to find the children of the
forest in order to stop the war against
the others while he was on this mission
the last heroes 12 companions either
died or disappeared but the last hero
eventually found the children of the
forest and together they were able to
send the others back to the far north
which led to the long night ending but
no one knows how the last hero was able
to end the fighting I'm assuming the
last hero was not able to kill all of
the White Walkers because they are back
again so some of them had to have
survived the long night I have always
believed that the last hero had to have
made some kind of a deal with the night
King or White Walkers to get the
fighting to stop the White Walkers were
winning this war during the long night
so why would they stop fighting and
decide to go back to the lands of always
winter unless they were offered
something whatever deal the last year
were made obviously worked the fighting
stopped then the wall was built to keep
the others out but this is when we hear
the tale about the night's king who was
the 13th Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch
the night's king took control of the
night fort on the wall when he ruled
there for 13 years with a woman who is
described as a female other she had pale
skin and blue eyes just like the White
Walkers do then eventually the night's
king ended up having sex with her and he
gave her his seed and together they
started sacrificing babies to the others
they did this for a while until
eventually the king and the north and
the king-beyond-the-wall put a stop to
this but we can see that sacrifices were
being made nearly 8,000 years ago an old
man has always believed that this
night's King was a stark I think she's
most likely right and that would mean
all of the babies being sacrificed to
the others back then had Starks blood
which is obviously a very powerful blood
then you fast-forward to the beginning
of this current story and we have
Craster sacrificing his babies to the
others and many people believe Craster
has Targaryen blood which is another
very powerful bloodline so now the
others have Targaryen babies being
turned into White Walkers when you think
about it all all of the White Walkers
were made up of either stark or
Targaryen blood because they've most
recently came from Craster who is
Targaryen and they used to come from the
night's king who ruled on the wall who
old nan said was a stark if all of this
is true which I believe it is then this
means the original night King had a very
strong interest in Targaryen and Stark
blood and this could have something to
do with the original pact that was made
with the last hero and the children of
the forest during the long night
I saw it
so
something say that job whatever it was I
daresay you'll see it again the last
hero may have promised the others a new
prince which is the prince who was
promised to the knight Cain a baby made
up of ice and fire stark in Targaryen
the night King might want a prince who
will eventually take his place and the
last hero may have promised this prince
over 8,000 years ago during the long
night the last hero had to have promised
something very special and important to
get the war to end or else the White
Walkers would have never accepted a
truce because they were winning the war
at the time why else would they give up
when they knew they could win all of
this leads me to what we have seen
lately it's obvious the knight King is
very interested in Jon Snow we already
know the night King has some sort of
greensight abilities we have seen the
night King interact with bran stark
inside the weirwood net
this means the night King may know some
things that everyone else does not know
kind of like the three-eyed Raven the
three-eyed Raven knew everything that
was going to happen before it happened
and the night King may have the same
kind of powers
you're the three-eyed Raven
I've been many things now I am what you
see my brother he let us see you and now
he knew what would happen from the
moment he left he knew and he went
anyway
how do you know I've been watching you
all of you the night King may have left
join alive because he knew John and
Daenerys would eventually meet and
create the prince who was promised made
up of Ice and Fire
when you think about it the night King
attacked the wall at pretty much the
same exact time John and Daenerys were
having sex the night King may know that
John gave Daenerys his seed and now it's
his time to come south and get the
prince who is promised to him the prince
who would eventually take the night
King's place as the leader of the others
I know this may sound crazy as hell to
some of you but I think this would be a
very interesting way to explain what the
night King actually wants but let me
know what you think about this crazy
idea do you think it's possible at all
or not a chance put your questions or
thoughts down below thank you all so
much for watching today's video I really
do appreciate that and thanks to each
and every one of you who support this
channel on patreon have a great day I
will see you in the next one bye oh my
sweet summer child what do you know
about fear fear is for the winter when
the snows fall and retreat deep fear is
for the long night when the Sun hides
for years and children are born and live
and die all in darkness that is the time
for fear my little Lord when the White
Walkers moved through the woods
you